welcome to this video playing aku boy
yep snot no name in them from the
Philippines two wins zero losses check
out a good score against him that seemed
oh my mouth was messy fight ah okay okay
so giving him a little bit of a head
start here yes I wanted to take on d5 of
course yeah it still have the odd weird
thing with this mouse but usually I'm
faring quite well with it i think it's
it's actually a good term a good device
it just takes a little bit of time to
adjust to well it's not it's not like
I'm losing here immediately it just it
just is totally unnecessary to to allow
this kind of thing okay so it's got some
pressure down before we will see one
rookie won this kind of moves
yeah training the sea pawn for the apron
it's not really what you want okay
young black has many options you can
that I did not consider that certainly
have certainly a move some things on e4
DTX Night Moves light XD forces idea
okay so maybe I want to put the rook out
of this diagonal I know maybe it takes
on c3 now just the simple move no okay
okay if I take you for d takes 9594
cheeks on e4 generally difficult 95-94
bishop cheeks a 492 check rookie to
quindi one loop the one should be too
hard to calculate really hard to
calculate now let's let's do something
simple just take this my home I just
take night takes you three down hmm now
anyway after this move three you can
expect so much from this from this game
p takes e4 I'm going 92 and take with
the knight on e4 not taking with the
rook the bad thing about my position is
of course is this this damage pawn
structure down upon a 2.9 c3 but I what
I have is I have a decent activity here
95 Bishop b5 I have some have some
activity there against against d5 for
example this is quite okay so if i take
on f6 now he has Queen takes and he's
attacking f2 this is a bit of a problem
so how can i play this Queen g44 look T
1 something like that maybe yeah
something like that if he takes on f6
and he takes on e5 and kun f6 I have
look at five maybe you can take their
pic should be 5 rupee 5 rook f2 is not
working King text we have six look at
five is going to be okay my idea is to
just play work T 1 here and maybe get
the d 5 points back somehow and I wanted
to make sure that it cannot easily play
rookie a door move like that
yeah he is certainly better but it's not
not totally apparent how we should play
at least not to me yeah it's going for
that but I have a look at five or queen
fi for that matter maybe Shahrukh rook
air-five it could be an ugly self pain
actually
he always has ripped it to in many
situations job I'm not sure him I don't
get this porn back easily Rudy not maybe
maybe take the rook takes rook the eight
I've got rooked e1 and if he goes Rudi
to maybe Bishop f1 is helping me I don't
know k x takes for c4 now is of course
still just better taking a very long
time though rook d2 was what I expected
but didn't happen okay but this just
looks like i have good chances to win
this this pawn ok so i RK is getting his
getting c3 immediately this is of course
not helping
hmm
I don't know is deformed yes just it
just has deform marching the palm but ok
I'm the the rook is not attacked because
this is hanging so I have Bishop before
move like that time workers to move the
rook back
maybe this one could be a bit irritating
as rook f2 mm-hmm jam check so maybe
this isn't such a bad defense in
comparison to some others look so i
don't get the pawn still he can go look
at two minutes to still don't get the
pawn check now you can just just bring
the king up probably
Jeff Jeff hmm Joe I am it's a draw grah
Harvard Gras our third brain are drawn
Jim Channon was a very lucky escape of
course yeah c5 this is really uh turley
ridiculous this move yeah the problem is
you have to be six um you can just take
you cannot support the pawn if this
would be possible that wouldn't be so
bad but it can go away five and now I
have no move yeah this is losing
everything so I just have to take and
what I did is I just traded see against
a pawn and I just strengthened black
Sanders so he's basically slightly
better right right out of the opening
with a better center and I really really
didn't have a great great idea here
probably probably i can improve
somewhere here I really underestimated
this thing here I thought I have enough
play against the d5 pawn but that's
definitely not the case i'm just a pawn
down and and and basically basically
losing here jo chalay played it you
played it very ok but at the end the
time didn't him didn't suffice for him
to win it I'm still position wise it was
winning for most of it this end game of
course yeah the big hair thing he OKs it
was a mouse lapeer the c5 move but this
is ready to be avoided it's a very bad
idea usually in the Queens gambit to
advance upon the only situations where
this is really feasible is where you can
really support the porn reliably and
this Bishop for example yeah there is
some there is a currently fashionable
line like this white is going C 5 but in
this situation White has clear here like
this this is not even the best move
water but yeah I can support the Pawnee
on c5 and this means that it will limit
this bishop and this night so this makes
some sense yeah grabbing this space but
in the the game move order I was forced
to take one on b6 and this is kind of a
kind of ridiculous okay well thanks for
watching